Ocelots are solitary animals
--they don’t spend much time hanging out
But they do leave “scented messages” for
each other
at ocelot latrines
Researchers used a dog to find 4 of these message boards
Camera traps at these locations captured 16
ocelots paying 63 visits in 6 months
The ocelots didn’t use the latrines daily
but stopped by occasionally to check messages
and leave their own
Marking territory is one use for these signals
but the latrines also help coordinate meetups
for males and females
Ocelots weren’t the only ones checking
these messages-
13 other species were captured on camera
Coatis came by in big groups
Tayras (a type of weasel) visited the latrines
even more than ocelots
And rodents, opossums, armadillos --
-- were also spotted
Researchers don’t know why ocelot latrines
are such a popular spot for different species
but now that they do--they can monitor them
for tracking elusive species
keeping track of biodiversity
and checking in on the impact of humans on these ecosystems